luz verde para la vacuna de facer
variante que en niños la decisión fue
tomada de forma abrumadora por la
administración de alimentos y
medicamentos de eeuu
efe
así que esto concluye la votación de los
18 miembros 17 votaron a favor y uno se
abstuvo de hardware en unos 28 millones
de niños estadounidenses entre 5 y 11
años que están regresando a clases
presenciales son elegibles para
aplicarse esta vacuna contra el jove y
19 según estudios clínicos de la
farmacéutica la vacuna tiene una
eficacia del 97 por ciento es la primera
en ser aprobada por eeuu para esta
población solo china cuba y los emiratos
árabes unidos han avalado vacunar a los
niños de estas edades claro si será la
tercera parte de la que se usa para los
adultos ya que según los expertos una
dosis más baja puede ayudar a que los
raros efectos secundarios sean menos
fuertes serán también dos dosis
aplicadas con tres semanas de diferencia
aunque aún falta que sea aprobada por
los centros para el control y la
prevención de enfermedades
ellos tienen previsto reunirse la
próxima semana y para mí la cuestión es
muy clara no queremos que los niños
mueran por él covite incluso si son
menos niños que adultos y no los
queremos en la uci
pero las tasas de vacunación en eeuu no
son las mejores del mundo el 58% de los
ciudadanos de este país se han vacunado
completamente en comparación con francia
o reino unido donde han alcanzado a
inmunizar a más del 70% de la población
el pasado 26 de octubre ya un panel de
consejeros de la actual administración
de la casa blanca había recomendado la
autorización de la vacuna para los
menores la autorización no garantiza que
muchos padres lleven a sus hijos a los
centros de vacunación